und jetzt das heute journal bettina
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend hinein
leicht und sorglos war das leben für die
menschen in afghanistan auch vor der
vergangenen nacht nicht vor 1 uhr 24
ortszeit als ein verheerendes erdbeben
den osten des landes heimsuchte auch das
noch die behörden sagen es gebe über
1000 todesopfer noch mehr verletzte und
diese zahlen dürften noch steigen seit
der machtübernahme der
radikal-islamischen taliban dort hat
sich die lage ohnehin deutlich
verschlechtert es fehlen lebensmittel
und medikamente von besserem schutz und
vorkehrungen gegen naturkatastrophen
ganz zu schweigen jörg brase berichtet
es regnet in strömen die straßen sind
aufgeweicht unser zdf kamerateam auf dem
weg ins erdbebengebiet für 40 kilometer
brauchen sie fünf stunden das team und
auch viele helfer versuchen mit dem auto
in die zerstörten dörfer zu kommen sie
schaffen es nicht vor einbruch der
dunkelheit ein augenzeuge berichtet
die meisten häuser wurden zerstört
keines blieb ohne beschädigungen hier im
bezirk jahren wurden ungefähr 500 leute
verletzt 60 wurden bei dem erdbeben
getötet
die an liegt nahe dem epizentrum des
bebens in der provinz paktika nahe der
grenze zu pakistan
einer von vier bezirken die dem erdboden
gleichgemacht wurden die bergregion ist
zunächst nur mit hubschraubern zu
erreichen so kommen am morgen die ersten
helfer aus der luft und sie finden ein
chaos vor mit bloßen händen graben die
überlebenden nach angehörigen in den
trümmern ihrer häuser von stunde zu
stunde wächst die zahl der toten und
verletzten die krankenhäuser der region
sind schnell überlastet die regierung
der radikalislamischen
taliban kommt in der hauptstadt kabul zu
einem krisentreffen zusammen und
verspricht den betroffenen schnelle
hilfe
familien die tote zu beklagen haben
bekommen von der regierung jeweils
100.000 afghani knapp 1100 euro und
familien mit verletzten rund 550 euro
außerdem ist ein medizinisches
versorgungszentrum
eingetroffen
die islamisten brauchen jede
unterstützung denn das beben trifft ein
land das er schon in beklagenswertem
zustand ist die taliban sind
international geächtet mit sanktionen
belegt nun sehen sie sich einer
katastrophe gegenüber die mit jeder
stunde größer wird
immer noch sind viele menschen
verschüttet viele häuser sind zerstört
die zahl der verletzten und getöteten
wird sicher noch steigen
den ganzen tag ziehen sie weitere opfer
aus den trümmern das beben geschah
vergangenen nacht tötete viele in ihren
betten im schlaf jetzt brauchen die
überlebenden dringend hilfe
wir liefern nahrungsmittel und zelte in
die region denn in dieser jahreszeit
kann es dort nachts sehr kalt werden in
einigen teilen des landes kann es nachts
sogar schneien
sie haben gräber ausgehoben viele
hunderte sie wollen die toten schnell
unter die erde bringen morgen werden sie
wahrscheinlich noch viele weitere graben
müssen
die johanniter auslandshilfe sorgt seit
jahren für die medizinische versorgung
in der jetzt vom erdbeben betroffenen
region verantwortlich dafür ist vor ort
louis marie nisten hermann reiners einen
guten abend
guten abend sie waren heute früh noch im
erdbebengebiet selbst noch im
erdbebengebiet was können sie uns von
dort berichten
ja genau ich war ich bin diesem mittag
zurückgekommen nach kabul und heute
nacht
hab zwar gab es ein schweres erdbeben
ganz schwer und nur in früher hatten wir
schon gehört dass es große schäden
gegeben hat in paktika provinz und cost
profit
and district nicht so weit vom host city
wo ich die nacht sowie das wollte ich
sie jetzt fragen wie es denn der kontakt
aktuell gibt es überhaupt kontakt zu den
betroffenen gebieten kann man da aktuell
hin
man kann dahin die kontakte sind
schwierig da die telekommunikation
auch nicht mehr funktioniert die
berichte kommen in kleinen kleine
zustande aber wie johann united nations
un
de facto motorrad ist haben hubschrauber
zu dem gebiet und gesendet auch und
verletzten nach die krankenhäuser zu
verschieben aber die berichte nicht alle
betroffenen dörfer haben wir jetzt haben
wir noch erreicht
so morgen morgen früh hoffen wir die
letzte information zu bekommen die
taliban behörden waren jetzt sehr
schnell mit den zahlen diese großen
zahlen diese furchtbaren zahlen über
todesopfer wie gesichert sind diese
angaben aus ihrer sicht
die sind ganz sicher der bestätigt die
un und die internationalen
hilfsorganisationen die menschen vor der
bereits e mail
gebiet haben oder in der nähe von das
gebiet haben so die die die nummer die
opfer und schäden die stimmen
wie können sie denn jetzt aktuell helfen
oder anders gefragt was was brauchen sie
jetzt um wirklich helfen zu können wir
brauchen viel medizinische hilfe
gesundheitsteams wir brauchen material
um die häuser zu sichern wasserdicht und
wasser und
winddicht zu machen wir brauchen nicht
hilfsgüter wie kleidung
material für das haushalt
brauchen sauberes wasser
ja und transport um die hilfsgüter nach
die gebiete zu bringen und um die
verletzte menschen nach krankenhaus in
anderen distrikt zu binden am rhein sind
wie hat man sich denn die zusammenarbeit
mit den taliban vorzustellen läuft das
professionell oder haben sie da auch
aktuell zu kämpfen mit vielen
beschränkungen
nein das verläuft sehr professionell die
taliban
haben
die leitung genommen die koordinieren
das hilfswerk die haben um
assistenz gefragt von die internationale
gemeinschaft um hilfe
gebeten und was ich ihm provinz gesehen
habe ist das ist sehr professionell und
in praktika provinz auch sagt lori
marino essen von der johanniter
auslandshilfe hermann reinders und
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch und
alles gute für sie oder ihre arbeit
danke schön und
das gespräch wir aus technischen gründen
vor eineinhalb stunden aufgezeichnet
nach deutschland so wie es ist kann es
nicht bleiben der satz kommt heute vom
bundesverkehrsminister er meint die bahn
aber diesen stoßseufzer hört man aber
tausendfach jeden tag auch von denen die
mit auto oder flugzeug oder fahrrad
unterwegs sind in diesem land
deutschland hat ein
infrastrukturprobleme endlose planungen
regulierungswut baustellenchaos
personalmangel sparmaßnahmen so wie es
ist kann es nicht bleiben eine
generalsanierung soll die bahn endlich
fit machen für die zukunft bis 2030 soll
ein hochleistungsnetz stehen kündigen
bund und bahn heute gemeinsam an wer als
fahrgast aktuell mit verspätungen
zugausfällen langsamfahrstrecken und
ausgefallenen klimaanlagen kämpft wird
das erst mal skeptisch zur kenntnis
nehmen gleichzeitig müssen sich
regierung und bahn chef an den
versprechungen jetzt messen lassen
stephanie heim
schick und schnell in die zukunft so
hätte die beiden es gern aber dass neun
euro ticket hat wieder mal gezeigt das
system bahn ist am limit vollgestopfte
personenzüge verspätungen wie lange
nicht und stehen die güterzüge wegen
schienennetz überlastung dazu immer neue
oft kleinteilige baustellen die für stau
auf den gleisen sorgen jetzt soll alles
besser werden und künftig setzen wir bei
den hoch belasteten korridoren auf
generalsanierung und radikale bündelung
über den gesamten korridor über alle
gewerke und über mehrere jahre der
gesamte streckenabschnitt wird dann
einmal für längere zeit gesperrt und ist
danach aber für viele jahre nahezu frei
aktuell gelten bei der baden 3500
kilometer strecke besonders im westen
als hoch belastet die prognose bis 2030
werden es über 9000 kilometer im ganzen
land seien ein hochleistungsnetz so
bezeichnen sie es heute soll entstehen
und so der zuständige minister die fürs
netz zuständige bahntochter soll in eine
gemeinwohlorientierte
gesellschaft überführt werden es geht um
mehr einfluss durch den bund mit dieser
infrastruktur sparte schaffen wir
effizienzgewinne bündeln parallele
führungsstrukturen und stärken die
steuerungsmöglichkeiten des bundes als
eigentümer
das zahlt gleichzeitig auf unsere
klimaziele 1 mir ist wichtig dass eine
strukturreform am ende mit einem
erkennbaren mehrwert für die bürgerinnen
und bürger verbunden ist die nötigen
milliarden stehen noch in keinem
haushalt doch am geld so beide werde es
nicht scheitern
an der stelle wird sich dann eigentlich
das problem zeigen dass sie das nicht
reichen wir haben nicht genügend planer
nicht genügend baufirmen in den letzten
jahren haben wir uns auf 1,5 milliarden
euro volumen ungefähr eingependelt und
wenn ich das jetzt für vier oder
fünffache dann muss ganz dramatisch die
frage gestellt werden wer soll diese
streckenplan wer soll sie bauen die
privaten güterbahnen bemängeln vor allem
dass kurzfristig keine verbesserungen in
sicht sind und auch von
gewerkschaftsseite kritik konkrete
aussagen konnten heute von herrn will
ich nicht gemacht werden er hat deutlich
gemacht das thema zur chefsache zu
machen zu wollen ohne zu erklären was
damit so werden soll für die reisenden
so viel scheint klar werden sich durch
viele neue baustellen etliche
fahrtzeiten zunächst verlängern die bahn
muss erst mal rechtzeitig informieren
dass etwas geplant ist und dann was sie
verlässliche baustellen fahrpläne machen
lieber etwas großzügiger planen es stört
den reisenden überhaupt nicht werden im
fahrplan steht er braucht 30 länger und
er braucht daher nur 20 umgekehrt wäre
es viel schlechter
das ganz grosse bauen soll 2024 losgehen
wenn alles so klappt wie heute verkündet
2024 also in eineinhalb jahren von jetzt
ich erwarte dass wir künftig nach der
bahn wieder die uhr stellen können sagt
der bundesverkehrsminister heute fragen
an ihn dazu nachher von gundula gause
pünktlich um 00 29
im heute-journal update
das wort gipfel wird die politische
agenda in den kommenden tagen prägen
eu-gipfel nato-gipfel g7-gipfel
letzterer ab dem wochenende im wahrsten
sinn des wortes zwischen lauter echten
gipfeln in den bayerischen alpen der
bundeskanzler hat in einer
regierungserklärung heute seine
erwartungen dargelegt im verhältnis zu
russland rechnet er mit einer langen
eiszeit für die ukraine will er einen
marshallplan aus berlin bernd band i
brüssel/madrid so sieht die sechstägige
gipfel route des kanzlers ab morgen aus
eu g7 nato davor aber berlin bundestag
in seiner regierungserklärung steckt
scholz sich selbst und den drei treffen
hohe ziele und den gipfeltreffen der
kommenden tage muss nicht nur die
botschaft ausgehen dass die europäische
union die nato und die g7 so geschlossen
zusammenstehen wie nie
sondern auch dass die demokratien der
welt zusammenstehen im kampf gegen
putins imperialismus
friedrich merz hatte den kanzler zuletzt
häufig und heftig kritisiert heute
auffallen viel lob für scholz für die
kreise das g7 gipfel management die neue
transparenz beim thema waffenlieferungen
im unterton aber schwingt immer die
selbe frage mit warum erst jetzt warum
nicht gleich so
begrüßen ausdrücklich dass nun auch
endlich die lieferung der waffen in gang
kommt es hatte offenbar in ihrer
regierung einen meinungswechsel gegeben
im hinblick auf die veröffentlichung und
auch auf die lieferung wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich wir hätten es uns früher
vorstellen können morgen reist scholz
nach brüssel und will die ukraine zum eu
beitrittskandidaten machen 27-mal jahr
von 27 mitgliedsländern das sei sein
ziel die linke fragt was bringt das der
angegriffenen ukraine wie soll dann ein
land auf das raketen regnet über 35
beitrags kapitel und mehr als hundert
tausend seiten des rechts bestandes der
eu verhandeln die debatte meine damen
und herren über den beitritt der ukraine
in die eu ist eine scheindebatte sie
kostet nichts aber sie lenkt ab afg chef
kuba fordert ein ende des sanktions
kurses gegen russland diesen so wörtlich
luxus in energiefragen könne man sich
nicht leisten auch sei ein eu beitritt
der ukraine
der falsche weg
die eu die angeblich für offenheit und
vielfalt steht ist eine gemeinschaft des
aufgezwungenen gemeinsinns und gerade
die länder des ostens die diese
erfahrung schon gemacht haben möchten
dass ein zweites mal nicht erleben mit
verlaub das folgt der ukraine was sich
gegen ihren freund wladimir putin gerade
verteidigt wie wollen teilt dieser
europäischen union sein das hat nichts
mit aufgezogen hai zu tun wenn ich ein
quatsch beim g7-gipfel sollte
ursprünglich die klimakrise hauptthema
sein mit dem krieg in der ukraine geht
es jetzt um die in trümmern liegende
friedensordnung die grünen mahnen man
müsse beide krisen gleichzeitig lösen
unter hunger nach fossilen energien er
hat uns nicht nur in ein massives
sicherheitsrisiko geführt sondern der
ist auf der anderen seite auch der
brandbeschleuniger für die klimakrise
und trägt die verantwortung dafür wenn
wir die zukunft unserer kinder zerstören
bevor es morgen für scholz zu den großen
gipfeln geht steht heute abend noch ein
kleiner an die koalitionspartner treffen
sich im kanzleramt das thema ähnlich wie
weiter in diesen krisenzeiten
ja da liegt also einiges auf dem tisch
schock unterlagen amt auch eine
gemeinsame idee aller koalitionsparteien
also der druck ist ganz besonders groß
dieser tage dass die koalition
gemeinsame antworten findet auf die
großen probleme allerdings liegen
momentan die ansichten vor allem bei der
frage der energiesicherheit und der
frage der in der
entschuldigung der inflationsbekämpfung
so weit auseinander dass sie sich für
heute wahrscheinlich noch keine einigung
vorgenommen haben
die man sieht da gräben die wieder
auftauchen die sind mal durch den
koalitionsvertrag zugeschüttet worden
kommen jetzt aber bei der lösung nach
gemeinsamen suchen nach verzeihung jetzt
bin ich ganz durcheinander bei der suche
nach einer gemeinsamen lösung kommen
diese unterschiede jetzt noch mal
besonders zum tragen spd und grüne zum
beispiel fordern weitere entlastungen in
dieser schwierigen situation für die
menschen die fdp sagt gegeben dafür aber
nicht die schuldenbremse auf dafür sagen
die liberalen bei der energiesicherheit
wiederum man könne auch über atomkraft
reden dass die grünen entschieden zurück
also hier ist für heute keine einigung
in sicht und deswegen gehen wir davon
aus dass in dieser sitzung vor allem ein
klärendes gespräch geführt wird darüber
wo man den gemeinsamen weg sieht wie man
gemeinsame lösungen angeht wir hören auf
jeden fall aus der runde das für heute
abend keine beschlüsse geplant sind die
hat man vorsichtshalber schon einmal auf
die nächste sitzung anfang juli
verschoben oder ganz herzlichen dank
nach berlin
und jetzt hier der blick auf weitere
wichtige nachrichten dieses tages und
den hast du ja christian im zweiten
anlauf hat das eu parlament mit großer
mehrheit für eine reform des
emissionshandels gestimmt es ist ein
herzstück des eu klimapakets mit dem
neuen kompromiss soll der
emissionshandel auf gebäude und verkehr
ausgeweitet werden zudem ist vorgesehen
dass die kostenlose vergabe von co2
zertifikaten ab
2032 entfällt das parlament sprach sich
außerdem für einen sozialen klima fonds
für einkommensschwache haushalte aus und
für eine art co2 soll an den
eu-außengrenzen
die vorhaben können allerdings erst in
kraft treten wenn sie mit den eu ländern
abgestimmt wurden
die prowestliche regierung bulgariens
ist durch ein misstrauensvotum gestürzt
worden die erst vor rund sechs monaten
gebildete koalition von
ministerpräsident koch hatte anfang juni
ihre mehrheit im parlament verloren nach
dem votum heute muss eine neue
regierungsmehrheit gefunden werden
gelingt das nicht kommt es zu neuwahlen
im streit um die in der ukraine
blockierten getreidevorräte sind
vertreter russlands und der türkei zu
gesprächen zusammengekommen im anschluss
daran verließ erstmals seit wochen ein
türkischer frachter den hafen von mario
rolle ob das schiff tatsächlich getreide
geladen hatte ist allerdings unklar
unterdessen gingen in der ost ukraine
die kämpfe unvermindert weiter in der
nacht soll die stadt bis die chance
erneut bombardiert worden seien derweil
berichtet russland über ein feuer in
einer ölraffinerie
nahe der ukrainischen grenze
durch einen drohnenangriff ausgelöst
worden sein
ab kommender woche sollen die ersten
ukrainischen soldaten am mehrfach
raketenwerfer des typs mars 2
ausgebildet werden das sagte
bundesverteidigungsminister in lambrecht
bei einer befragung im bundestag
deutschland wird drei der systeme
liefern genauso wie großbritannien die
usa liefert 4 hambrecht erklärte
außerdem die bundeswehr sei mit den
bisher gemachten zusagen an der grenze
dessen angelangt was noch verantwortbar
sei wenn die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung noch gewährleistet
werden solle
wir gegen diskriminierung vorgehen soll
wer sich für den schutz von allen die
wegen ihrer herkunft religion oder
sexuellen orientierung benachteiligt
werden einsetzen soll wer gar die
offizielle antidiskriminierungsstelle
der bundesregierung leiten soll muss
selbst eine starke stimme haben wissen
wie man sich gehör verschafft keine
frage aber darf eine
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte auch
selbst spalten selbst polarisieren wie
es ihr kritiker vorwerfen das ist die
diskussion aktuell zu einer
personalentscheidung der ampelkoalition
die selbst die mitglieder der
ampelkoalition nicht mehr alle
unterstützen die publizistin ferda
ataman sollte eigentlich diese woche in
das amt gewählt werden das ist jetzt
erstmal verschoben kamran seit jahren
über die hintergründe
sie provoziert act an ist unbequem ferda
ataman streitbare publizistin mit
türkischen wurzeln
die 43 jährige früher redenschreiberin
von armin laschet ist bestens in politik
und medien vernetzt jetzt soll sie auf
vorschlag des kabinetts
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte des
bundes werden eine gute wahl sagen spd
und grüne
7 emotionales thema jeder in diesem land
hat einen bezug zum thema
diskriminierung und rassismus und alle
werden laut und deswegen braucht es eine
person die klar aussprechen kann was
sache ist und die gegenüber der politik
auch positionen durchsetzen kann die
vielleicht nicht unbedingt bequem sind
oder jedem gefallen bei derart ammann
hat in den letzten jahren auf
diskriminierungs strukturen diesem land
hingewiesen jeglicher art und das hat
sie sehr pointiert gemacht dass sie
dabei nicht immer nur mit
samthandschuhen reingegangen ist es
richtig harter mann polarisiert
2020 schreibt sie die spiegel kolumne
albanisch oder wie nennen wir kartoffeln
darin hält sie weißen deutsche nur
einheimischen und germanen nachfahren
vorüber empfindlich auf das wort
kartoffel zu reagieren 2018 legt sich
ferda ataman
mit dem damaligen innenminister seehofer
an er rücke mit seinem heimatbegriff in
die nähe der blut und boden ideologie
beleidigt bleibt seehofer danach dem
integrations gipfel fern selbst aus der
regierungspartei fdp kommt kritik gegen
der teuteberg twittert meine stimme
bekommt sie nicht ablehnung auch aus der
union frau ackermann ist dafür bekannt
dass sie diskriminierung gegen die
deutsche mehrheitsgesellschaft für
legitim hält das hat sie geschrieben sie
hält diskriminierungen teilweise für
andere migrantische communitys die
nichtmuslimische sind auch für weniger
beachtenswert also frau ackermann ist
eine persönlichkeit die sicherlich
polarisiert und spaltet die nicht
zusammenführt und versöhnt hat hamann
kennst aus das sagen heute auch mehr als
30 migrantinnen in einem offenen brief
sie raten der ampel koalition von der
wahl ackermanns ab auch weil sie heikle
themen ausblende sie ist nicht besonders
offen für die debatte zum politischen
islam zur kleinkriminalität
ehrenmorde zwangsheiraten solche dinge
setzt die in anführungsstriche eine
person die uns hier in deutschland als
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte
vertreten soll sollte ihrerseits keine
diskriminierungen äußerungen tätigen
insbesondere gegen die
mehrheitsgesellschaft gegen deutsche sie
als kartoffel bezeichnen dann wären sie
gleichzeitig selber genervt ist wenn man
sie nach ihrer herkunft fragt polemische
tweets ölförder ackermann inzwischen
gelöscht haben gestern sucht sie das
gespräch mit den fraktionen sie selbst
will sich erst nach ihrer wahl im juli
äußern wer wie fährt man gegen
diskriminierung antritt muss einen
spagat leisten
klartext reden unbequem sein und dennoch
versöhnen können
und jetzt in der sendung noch mal
wirtschaft mit johanna und zwar mit
schlechten nachrichten für die ford
mitarbeiter im saarland der us-autobauer
hat beschlossen künftig im spanischen
valencia seiner elektroautos zu bauen
und nicht in saarlouis etwa
4600 beschäftigte sind betroffen valerie
haller was bedeutet diese entscheidung
für die mitarbeiter das bedeutet dass
sie weiter um ihre jobs bangen müssen
ihre beschäftigungsgarantie läuft
nämlich 20 25 aus und wie es dann weiter
geht s noch völlig offen die mitarbeiter
sind sauer monatelang hatten sie auf den
zuschlag für das elektroauto gehofft
politiker hatten klinken geputzt doch
das half nichts drei jahre noch
produziert ford in saarlouis autos
danach wird damit wohl schluss sein
neben den 4600 stellen bei ford stehen
außerdem weit über 1000 jobs bei lokalen
zulieferern auf dem spiel ford ist ein
großer arbeitgeber im saarland der
verlust des werks wäre ein schwerer
schlag für das land aus vorsicht es mit
der entscheidung für valencia nicht
automatisch das ende für den standort
saarlouis verbunden der konzern hat nun
eine task force eingerichtet ausgang
ungewiss wie begründet fort denn das
valencia den zuschlag bekommen hat also
die beiden ford werke valencia und
saarlouis haben sich einen ziemlich
harten internen bieterwettbewerb
geliefert spanien hat gewonnen weil es
dort günstiger sei hieß es aus der
zentrale das ist aber nur ein teil der
wahrheit ford hat wie andere autobauer
zu viele produktionsstätten in europa
die werden nun schritt für schritt
geschlossen saarlouis ist aber auch ein
beispiel dafür dass der umstieg vom
verbrennungsmotor kaum ohne job verluste
geht
nach frankfurt
um die zukunft des fliegens geht es
gerade auf der internationalen luft und
raumfahrtausstellung in berlin und die
soll deutlich nachhaltiger aussehen mit
blick auf den klimawandel begrüßte
bundeskanzler scholz bei der eröffnung
das ziel der branche bis 2050
klimaneutral zu werden
die aussteller zeigen wie das gelingen
soll zum beispiel durch wasserstoff und
brennstoffzellen oder auch durch
batteriebetrieb zu den lottozahlen sie
lauten 7 23 29 34
36 46 superzahl 5 alle angaben wie immer
ohne gewähr
es hatte sich in den vergangenen tagen
bereits angedeutet nun ist es offiziell
der fc bayern münchen hat stürmers
dahmani vom fc liverpool verpflichtet
und heute in münchen präsentiert der 30
jährige senegalese der in der
vergangenen saison 23 tore für liverpool
lancierte erhält in münchen einen
dreijahresvertrag
die ablösesumme soll bei mehr als 30
millionen euro
wie erleben die menschen in russlands
hauptstadt diesen sommer wie sieht ihr
alltag im schatten des krieges gegen die
ukraine aus das auslandsjournal hat zwei
russen begleitet einen gegner und eine
glühende anhängerin von präsident putins
politik es lohnt sich gleich nach uns
hier im zdf und morgen hier in diesem
heute-journal freuen sich marietta
slomka und heinz wolf auf sie wir sagen
danke fürs interesse und wir wünschen
ihnen jetzt einen schönen abend bis bald
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch frido wird bis
morgen abend weiter nach osten ziehen
und das -tief chiara weiter nach norden
für uns bedeutet das einen recht ruhigen
donnerstag mit nur wenigen schauern und
gewittern die gibt es heute nacht auch
in süddeutschland sonst aber ist es
meist klar und die temperaturen sinken
auf 17 grad am oberrhein und bis 8 grad
hier in schleswig holstein die
höchsttemperaturen morgen ging an der
ostseeküste bei 22 grad sonst wird es
aber überall sommerlich warm bis heiß
mit 26 bis 32 grad und die höchsten
temperaturen gibt es zum beispiel rund
um emmerich der vormittag wird sehr viel
sonne bringen es gibt nur kleine
quellwolken das ändert sich am
nachmittag dann entwickeln sich hier im
schwarzwald am oberrhein aber auch
westlich des rheins einige gewittert und
am freitag werden dann hoch und tiefe so
perfekt östlich und westlich von uns
liegen dass sie die warme luft aus
richtung mittelmeer heranziehen und das
mittelmeer ist aktuell ungewöhnlich warm
für ende juli mit werten zwischen 24 und
27 grad im ergebnis bedeutet das einen
unwetter freitag mit kleinen königen
hagel mit sturmböen und auch mit
platzregen sind diese gewitter verbunden
sie werden im äußersten osten zwischen
dem erzgebirge und der ostseeküste noch
nicht ankommen das passiert am samstag
der sonntag bringt dann neue unwetter
von westen ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend